[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
can hear us what's going on you guys
gaming out here here with hustle and
motivate what's going on hustle
hey what's up with you eddie how's it
going man i'm doing better than i was
doing last week you know let me
apologize first off for us not going
live last week i it was kind of
strategic but at the same time i was in
no
like i made a video people was deemed
like an addict while you make the video
but not the podcast it's easier to make
a 10 minute video that it is to talk for
an hour and a half to two hours
uh so
so very true i went through with that
and part of me felt like maybe i should
leave because i knew we were doing that
big
show sunday i knew that
way before
the attic show so because we were having
chase money and 3mg on and cognito you
know started pitching more information
to me about like wanting to put more
people and then i was all right then we
need to go all out and that that's when
we started getting that giant list of
people it was like 20 some people
yeah it was definitely a uh i would like
to say a who's who from all different
podcasts from you know
dsps comcast weapon wheels etc etc uh
colin's last stand he you know y'all saw
him in hole pull up that was that was
fun i wasn't expecting that and uh
for the record i didn't know that was
gonna happen and you can actually like
see me getting surprised when they
pulled up i said what the hell i said oh
all right
it was just the thing but yeah you know
no podcast last week which kind of
worked out for me because
i get to running around i got to run
errands and do family stuff and we
talked behind the scenes about stuff
like that so it kind of just worked out
for me just not being available anyway
because it was i'm running around there
because i hit you that morning and i
only think i asked you what you do on
the podcast i'm like damn i don't know
because i had to take care of some
personal stuff anyway so i mean it
worked out for me
and it worked out for you guys in the
long run too um and if you guys haven't
done so after the podcast y'all make
sure y'all go check out the most recent
episode of iop was that the highest
rated view podcast you guys there yeah
by far definitely
i think like right now sitting at like
33 000. you know i want to appreciate
everyone for coming through you know
anyone that hasn't watched it you know
definitely go check it out but you know
that
a lot the majority of that podcast you
got to go there go on twitter thank
cognito
because i ain't got a lot of you guys i
was against the massive amounts of
people showing in like i did i was i was
the one that
pitched the idea of calling to come on
because i wanted more of a like you know
a balanced show
but for the most part
the amount of people that showed in
that was all cog is the one
that orchestrated all of that stuff and
and shout out to him because it is not
easy to manage that many people coming
in and out uh originally i was supposed
to help with
like pretty much like releasing the
faucet like letting people in and out
but the problem with it was is like we
didn't test that feature to the last
minute so cog had to do all of that uh
so you know uh we we are in talks of
making something like that a yearly
thing we don't know how we're gonna do
it but we might do that like once a year
i don't know yet i'm not going out there
and giving out any information i'm not
supposed to but uh keep in mind that you
know we saw the high criticis we saw the
high praises for that type of show we
can't do that weekly let me let me point
that out now
that was very mentally
draining for me because it was so
long but you guys are pulling up in the
thousands we had like up to 1900 people
we had i think it ended at like 12 like
1500 likes or some crazy number like
that so obviously you know if if the
viewership likes it you guys want it
we're gonna sit through five six hours
of a podcast and but you know it was a
nice i can't say a lot of the times like
three hours go by and i didn't oh it's
three hours already
i noticed that one
but you guys enjoyed it so that's all
that
really matters at the end of it
so
without any further ado let's go ahead
and start the show he's like you know we
got hustle motivate here what have you
been playing here recently hustle
i have been playing the game of life aka
no well no new games anyway i've been
playing like aladdin but that stuff like
that don't count i got something called
a retro tank 5x oh wait i'm lying i'm
live friday i ran a hello multiplayer
but i i was testing out my retro tank as
well my ogx box
the rest of my nintendo wii as well
nintendo
yeah yeah
look at the drawers see what it was it's
a nintendo wii it works with all that
stuff so it's pretty much an upscaler i
may have mentioned it here i think i
mentioned on one of my live streams so
when i come back to live streaming i'll
be streaming like retro stuff and i
think i mentioned that here too but like
i pretty much just been running through
that like i said i got a little time
there um with the troubleshooters over
on friday so we have fun playing halo
they um hey eric if you played hello
have you played attrition
no but i need to jump on there and try
that how exactly is that like i don't i
can't get it exact it just looks like a
slayer match to me like explain
attrition to me
okay so pretty much you have it's like
well i know you're not a fan of gears
but it's kind of like gears tdms where
like you'll start with in this case
you'll start with seven lives your team
will have seven lives you can burn
through those lives and the second you
get down to the final four let's say if
i kill two of the opposing team members
they have a little bubble which
represents like it's like like a souls
bubble right like their soul will come
up
and the their teammates can revive them
if they can get to them so you you hold
right bumper in my case you all right
bumper and your team their teammates can
get to them um
it kind of turns into like once you get
like it turns into like a super good
thing for me because i don't like the
long 50 you know 50 person slayer match
50 kill slayer matches and nothing like
that what i love about this is that you
can't just rush in and when you see you
know the opposing team once you got
their little bubbles on the ground you
know somebody's going to try to run
toward a power weapon or you know they
could be you know and they could be
cameron somewhere but they they just
kind of stopped the camping so it has
like a um pub g overwatch type of thing
the way that this red bubble comes in i
forget what they call it but this the
map will
get smaller so you can't camp out and
just be out and about with the power
like power soul power weapons and all
that you really got to get in there and
get active you can't just sit around and
camp and wait for people to come by like
it's a super dope moment
that's interesting i have to actually
try it i've been meaning to jump on here
recently i've been playing yu-gi-oh for
three days man
you know what's funny that master dual
thing
okay okay
it's cross
play and cross progression
i don't recommend you play this on the
switch the performance is gone awful
like every they can't even play a
yu-gi-oh game on this switch
they need a new switch
they need a new switch it's it's very
clear at this point it's very clear but
you know i really enjoyed it and um i'm
going to continue playing it uh the the
bad thing about it is i can't play it on
my on steam right now because apparently
if you start a a match well if you
started an account you can't delete that
account to cross
to cross progress the rest of your
accounts so i have my switch my
playstation and my xbox linked but it
won't let me link it to my steam because
i accidentally start an account on my
steam so it won't let me delete that
account on my steam to link it with the
other ones which i don't know maybe i
ought to send them an email it should be
switched or is it simpler than that i
don't know what you know
anyway
real quick hey shout out to the people
in the chat funds i see you replicant i
see you only on xbox being your best
behavior today sir pixel bit g i see you
king reaper thank you logic wins you
were one of the first ones here and uh d
nasty
we appreciate you all for coming by um
and akw everybody who else who comes in
here hey about about the yu-gi-oh game
is it turn-based like the normal ones or
is this different cause you said the
switch couldn't run it and i'm just
curious to see what type of game it is
yeah it's turn based um so you know
pretty much how it is i really need to
turn off that
give me 15 seconds i got to turn off my
tv
in case you guys didn't notice like
there's a light that's coming on my like
right side that's like my tv when it
gets light
i don't know why that that's on i should
have turned it off before
nothing that my phone and an app can't
fix see watch watch you're going to see
this light right here this light right
here it's just going to go away look
look it just went away
off with your phone
yeah
use a remote like normal people i have a
remote but i don't know where it's at at
the moment i'm not looking for it but
anyway let's go ahead and start the show
man this is the attic show where we talk
about the past present and future gaming
got my co-host with me hustle and
motivate and we're going to talk about
these plans man we got activision we're
going to talk about because we missed it
last week and then we're going to talk
about mine and hustle's individual plans
and you know our motives exactly as
content creators and in games what
you're looking forward to what's your
goals for 2022 and then we're going to
talk about these new star wars and the
fact that school that the ea
has dropped battlefront and somehow
respawn has picked up everything else so
anyway let's let's what do you want to
talk about first uh
well i'll say we can kind of leave the
star wars one for last because the xbox
activision thing even though we are a we
laid on it it kind of is going to roll
into the second topic so we can actually
start here if you don't mind all right
so we'll start with the xbox buys
activision for those of you that's in
the chat that have been living under a
rock
microsoft last tuesday announced that
they bought activision
and this is a huge thing in terms of
industry wise but to me itself i didn't
care
because i don't really care about a lot
of their games besides like maybe
overwatch but they did buy them and it
really does
show up on
what exactly that means in the industry
so there's a couple things i want to
really talk about
first off i want to talk about the call
of duty thing and whether or not
they're going to do anything with call
of duty and we might even bring up the
phil spencer tweet i don't think he
really answered anything in that tweet
partially but obviously we'll have to
talk about that and then we're going to
talk about our personal wishes
that could happen with this
this this acquisition
and then
first thing i want to talk about is
hustle how bad would it be
if
the government shut this down this deal
down
oh
um i don't think that that's gonna
happen i'm glad you asked that question
i personally don't think that that's
gonna happen um
you know microsoft you know they got a
team of lawyers they're my strongest
linebackers shout out the whole glow who
was on the podcast sunday who's on the
lp podcast on sunday man and
um this won't happen i i think before
they even before activation once
activation came to
came to microsoft you know purchase the
lawyers was on that like hey we got to
make sure that this doesn't look a
certain way and um you know with all of
the facts that we know now and i'm kind
of glad we are talking about this a week
later
microsoft is still in third place
tencent is is big dog out here they're
number one sony is number two
and even with this acquisition microsoft
is still number three in the marketplace
so let's you know let's let's calm down
on the whole monopoly talk this deal
still will go through by the way and i
couldn't
i couldn't imagine a world to where it
wouldn't go through because i don't
think that
microsoft would have even played
themselves and even tweeted this out i
don't think that phil spencer has that
long you know
i don't know what you want to call him a
dear diary letter i don't know what you
call them things when they put it on the
xbox blog post and all that
i don't think he would have even wasted
this time had they had they thought that
this would have fell through
um
i want you to answer that question i
have another question for you yes sir
personally i feel like
because there is a possibility this will
go through and i don't think it's very
high
but there is a possibility because at
the end of the day i do feel like
microsoft has a
a team of lawyers just sitting somewhere
that were literally just crunching
numbers and the possibilities that this
wouldn't go through wouldn't go through
it and it was clearly made a little bit
ago like not a long like people need to
realize too that this is something this
was done at the last minute too this
isn't something that was done six
minutes six months ago or a year ago
like this is probably within three
months that this was
uh decided and i don't think they would
come out publicly unless they pretty
much talk to everyone and they're like
yo
once the paper works through that's what
it'll be official but we're pretty much
telling you we're not gonna deny it like
so i do think that there's a good chance
like probably a 80 85 percent chance of
sales what's your second question
um ooh
my second question is are you surprised
at the time that this took because you
remember like the first that that
cinemax deal they said that deal was
like a year like a year in the making
you know now granted activision came to
microsoft this time around but this was
for all intents and purposes what four
months
right this they just said i think he
said they came to him in october
and hustle math that's three months but
it doesn't matter like the fact that it
happened so quickly like the like they
approached them and they had to make
sure they you know t's were crossed and
eyes were dotted so on and so forth
you know if we didn't like enough i'm
glad we're doing this today because
my my first initial thought was yo how
long they been talking to them
if this is 10 times the amount of that
zenimax deal
the activision blizzard deal
like how long how long were
conversations going on i was like really
and truly surprised to know that they
only went on for a few for a handful of
months less than that it was just it was
just like the why that's the wildest
thing to me like especially when you're
dealing with that type of money and
hey adam before you go
is it natalia what was his name phil i
wanna make sure i get his name right now
phil spencer but the other gentleman who
just pretty much gave him the blank
check they're all in on gaming though
this is
69. or 68.7 billion dollars
yeah and they paid for that in cash by
the way which i didn't mention the iop
they paid for straight cash on me which
is insane
who you telling microsoft let's just
take that in hustle microsoft has
cash just laying around
that is equal to more than nintendo is
worth
man no stocks no bonds
no no partnership no merging no no it's
money hold on i'll be back y'all let me
let me get the money off the shoe box
don't go nowhere like what
that that's insane yeah microsoft
microsoft found enough money
in the couch cushions to pay for
activision
man
yeah um
i do want to respond to a couple of
people in the chat a replicant
yeah hey you know what
i'm so glad you said it's a huge l if uh
facebook or amazon didn't get them yeah
it is but i would much pref i would
rather prefer microsoft actually get
them i was talking about physical media
yesterday um
i played the order 1886 which is a
really good game by the way if you i
haven't played it it's like five dollars
go pick it up right
ready at dawn don't even work with
playstation no more they got picked up i
think by facebook as a matter of fact
they got picked up by facebook and i
think they're doing vr stuff i ain't
been to playing on vr stuff so now you
know like just can you just imagine can
you just imagine like what the
alternatives were just like different
alternatives for amazon they don't
really you know i'm not gonna say they
don't know what they're doing but they i
don't know if their heart is in it we
know google's heart isn't in it don't
flag the videos you know google don't
play the video but we know that they we
know that they hardly end this for real
they're steadying that man standing
you're not making no noise here you got
you got money you got bread you got
capital but
it it seemed like
this is like perfect time at least for
microsoft because
it seemed like phil like he actually
like getting in he getting it on them
sticks he's only he seemed like he cared
and that's that's just what that means
you know means to me now for the record
i do want to say this
i'm not no call of duty dude but y'all
know me and if you don't know me by now
y'all gonna get to know that i'm big on
like game preservation i'm more
concerned about everything going all
digital and things not being available
over time
and i still want my physical media but
like
i i may have to take this little l just
to have it all playing game pass i just
hope they still make physical copies and
stuff
i think
i do think we're in a world where
physical copies is gonna be something
that you're gonna have to physically ask
for like it's not gonna be something
that you could just go into a store and
buy i'm not saying that future is right
now but i do think it is coming
all right so
now
clearly
they did spend the 50 the 60
60 some
mil billion with a b
keep that in mind with a b
they spent that on activision but
apparently what has been going around is
they actually have a lot more money that
they really feel like they have to spend
before
uh the queue is over because i guess
their mentality is
with inflation
they want to spend their money now to
have actual you know ips and stuff going
into the future so
let's say that they do have money left
over what would you prefer them to do
with that money
as far as like a
studio acquisition or like a publisher
any position anything
well i would say i would say uh bandan
ban namco is who you would go after
because now
with the acquisition i mean with the
acquisition of activision blizzard and
so on and so forth with that big
acquisition
you literally and i mentioned this on
our people i didn't go into detail you
can literally rival nintendo now so if
you really wanted a super smash brothers
clone for all intents and purposes you
can do that a fun fact for the people
who may or may not know
namco made super smash brothers ultimate
i got that game in the weed it's in here
somewhere i don't know what it is but
they actually like made that
i mean yeah you know they everybody
praised the soccer rapper bandai navco
was the one who kind of kind of pulled
up on that i did a little research on
that so i know i'm right too and i've
heard that from several sources plus i
played the game like hell too
but i would want to see
their version of a super smash brothers
we had spoken on this before
and
you know i do want to see killer
instinct come back in some type of way
and it will and i want to make something
about this deal too
um
i don't
see them getting that money back anytime
soon but what i do see once because call
of duty is gonna become an exclusive
title that that game come on we we know
you getting on xbox getting on gamepads
whatever
that's gonna fund other projects
um and that's i don't know if that was
something that i didn't get a chance to
mention on sunday but that's gonna fun
other projects and we're gonna see
different studios like like a high noon
like those support studios we're going
to see them ultimately get their own
shot at what they want to make um what
i've noticed with microsoft just been
covering different things here and there
phil spencer kind of changed the culture
in terms
of they're not forcing people to really
make
what microsoft wants them to make
they're giving you opportunities like a
ninja theory to make um not hellblade
but um
attic we know the name of the
multiplayer game that didn't do so well
um
bleeding
is that this
i know what it is
thank you sir yes so so they had the
opportunity to continue that um passion
project and bleeding edge so it's not
like microsoft is denying people that
create creativity the coalition well my
favorite studio over there at microsoft
they're not even working on gears
they're actually working on something
else they're working on a mystery new ip
and i can't wait for that they're gonna
use the unreal engine five and you know
it is what it is i i just can't wait to
see that in particular so
creatively these other studios will get
an opportunity to flex um
toys for bob they're gonna make you know
i would i would be hard-pressed to think
that they wouldn't make a banjo kazooie
they would all the kitty titles that
sort of compete with nintendo i will be
harvesting someone else is already
making of andre kazooie
yeah okay and that very well is a
possibility but i don't
that that's perfect for for them for
like they can bring back you know blinks
the time sweeping don't laugh that's one
of the first xbox games i've played
don't laugh at me yeah i know but they
could they can literally bring that back
they can bring back part three or you
know the other sequel and that those
possibilities are endless and i i kind
of went on a little bit i ain't meaning
to so my fault i got my phone my phone
you're fine
i feel like when it comes to
[Music]
this particular topic i do think that
it's going to be very good for them like
i
i want to think that
they're going to be able to really
go with this like but i just got to see
exactly
what they do with call of duty like
that's the biggest thing because what
they do if call of duty is going to show
me
how determined they are with this
activision thing uh you know i do have a
you know something else particular we're
going to talk about when it comes to
call of duty uh we're not going to
really talk about that right now but the
the biggest thing that i would like is
how do you feel
about you know because what i want to
see them do is just
unless it's like a sega or something
i don't want them to buy any
buy any more studios i want them to stay
away from
studio acquisitions unless it's
something eastern like a sega or van
damko perhaps or something they could
give them
a diversity that they don't currently
have and i think they're really lacking
anything japanese related so unless they
can get that i feel like they need to
stay away from that because
to me
activision and what they have because
with activision what they have done when
they got that activision hustle as they
have successfully
locked down the first person shooter
market and the rpg market
oh for sure western rpgs for sure so
so when it comes to that we'll get to
superchat one second when it comes to
that if you want to play first person
shooters even if call of duty is remains
on playstation we could agree even if it
remains on playstation
they're going to hardcore push you
towards the xbox brand
they're going to go on this dlc first or
even dlc exclusive
you probably when it comes to like
warzone i would not be surprised if you
start seeing like
um what's that thing called
uh spartan
uh like you start seeing uh master chief
ammo or something like that someone get
this christopher heart dude up out of
here that's definitely not christopher
art uh i was gonna ask you that yeah
get him up out of here i don't know why
people will be weird it is what it is
i'm not gonna address it anymore if you
see something use your best uh you you
use your
your best thinking and just get them out
of here but
so
i personally feel like
they need it unless it's like a sega or
something like that you know one that
they bought from software
from software would make a lot of people
mad i think they need to
stick more towards let's go ahead and
show them
[Music]
game pass games day and day try to go
with their elden ring drop the bag put
that in their day and day go over their
dying light to drop the bag go there in
day and day because i do feel like they
have showed you
you need to own
an xbox series x and xbox series s with
game pass there's plenty of value in the
future but i think
i don't know about you hustle but my
opinion is they haven't showed you in
short-term value if it's worth having
right now
and i think they need to do a little bit
better on that where you know sure i
think we'll be lit in a year to two
but i don't know about right now because
there's not really a lot coming out
exclusivity wise this year and i'm not
saying they're not going to do that
because they have been known to hit
those triple a's like we just saw with
extraction i liked extraction i don't
know why other people didn't i get it
people want some
random experience
my question to the chat is what did you
expect
it's extraction like people sitting
there like complaining about where the
game plays it's rainbow's six siege
gameplay we know it was going to do this
why are you surprised but
we're going to go ahead
and get this fight fight super trap from
mr irishman have you guys seen the link
from jazz and nick from xbox era about
the master chief collection type
remaster coming from
xbox probably gears
i have not seen that so what you're
saying is that
coalition is making a remaster of of
master chief collection
i don't know how i felt but you know
would be crazy hustle i know this would
never happen because i don't think they
would ever do this but you know what
would be crazy is if
they
[Music]
have gears
coalition
make a make a halo game
as a third person action adventure off
the same merits that the original halo
was so it's the same game
but maybe instead of playing master
chief you're playing like a
like uh
like a soldier or something
and it's like a cover shooter
and like you fight alongside master
chief instead of being him
i mean
not only well i mean i kind of feel like
they should do that um
we you when you play you played in b
halo reach so we could have another one
of those you could have another one of
those the way you could have like this
third person ask type character who's a
lot different from master chief i don't
know
maybe you can make them or whatever
maybe you can make your own character
but
that would actually be dope shout out to
the coalition for actually like in my
opinion like they're the heart and soul
of microsoft as far as i'm concerned you
know i'm a gears dude all day they had
um they had xbox when they back last
generation as y'all know gives four
guests tactics gives five make sure i
get it all together
so with that being said i would love to
see something from them in regards to
that but they yeah they probably won't
do that i'm looking for that tweet that
jizz
wait did did jess tweet this out i
haven't seen it i did see something
related to that but i didn't really
investigate they're saying it could be a
gears or fable collection
i could see a fable collection um i do
think that if you want to successfully
sell
fable
whatever this if it's a remake or fable4
whatever that is
oh the twitch chat is only in sub chat i
apologize for that baron we'll figure
out what's going on with twitch later or
maybe i will i'll figure it out when uh
hustle talks to be honest with you uh
bear i don't even know how to get it out
of uh sub chat only uh i don't really be
doing twitch like that but i will look
into it here in a moment but how do you
feel if they because here's my thing if
they want to bring fable back
i think he'll do good but a better way
of doing it is like maybe sometime next
year the beginning of the year after
because i think fable
is coming out in 2024
but maybe sometime next year you drop
like a fable one remaster like remake
like build fable one from the ground up
and
and get people hyped up to play fable
again and then
you know
they now said the e3
or maybe not e3 i feel like you don't
want to announce it maybe
if you're going to show gameplay for
fable
i feel like showing gameplay for one and
for both is going to be overkill
like so maybe maybe
okay okay new new plan new plan guys new
plan all right so
fable we get at e3 whatever they do with
that e3 digital vietnam uh
next year and then the yeah and then the
exo or the video game awards which i
think they need to stop doing stuff with
the video game awards and do it at xo
but i get it more people whatever we're
not talking about that
at that exo to video game awards that's
when you show the fable gameplay
uh so you know you get people hyped up
with that fable uh remake from e3 a
couple months ago and then three or four
months later you you you show them that
fable remake or fable4 whatever they
want to call that
i don't know you show them that gameplay
and i feel like that would actually
really resonate with a lot of people
because
a lot of people in this chat someone uh
jason said i don't like fable i don't
know if you've played fable or and
fable's outdated as well
uh so you know maybe if they brought
fable back they made it look nicer they
made the combat better
maybe you would like that than what you
see now and i think they need to really
show
what an updated fable can be before we
see the updated fable but that's just my
opinion on that and we completely went
left with that super chat anything else
you want to talk about with that super
chat
we we did um
yeah no no at first i thought you were
talking about the
game that act that blizzard's working on
because blizzard apparently announced
something this morning i don't know if
you uh call when did that but they
announced that they were working on like
an open world game this morning and
apparently supposed to be on consoles
shout out to nebu nebu knight who have
you say his name on twitter that's why
follow i saw it all this morning i said
um
i said all right that may be a little
too little too too much but
there is a lot going on um let's see
blizzard is developing a survival game
for pc and console um set in the new
universe and that news article is here
if you uh if i want to you know i'm
going to be wrong i'm kind of so tired
of survival game i don't know maybe
blizzard
maybe blazer can make a survival game
like
i'm tired of like the arcs the
um the groundeds like i kind of want
different experiences
but
it it would be if anyone could do a
blizzard could do a really high quality
one so you know i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna say that they don't need to do it
or need to do it i'm sure the people
that make the survival experience games
and the people that love that genre they
want to see one made by blizzard and
i'll never like speak down on it like
blizzard shouldn't make that like look
the good thing about being an xbox fan
right now
is just because one or two they still
just making something i don't what i
care about
it doesn't mean that the rest aren't man
we we we live in a time right now
where
everyone is making something that might
not be for you but someone else right
beside them is making something for you
i might not care about hellblade 2 at
all whatsoever
it's not scratching any itch at all but
then when i look at that vow i'm like
that looks nice
so it's um
it's definitely a
a wide range of variety for well for
everybody like you're a perfect dog for
me got fatal for you um
cog is playing whatever he's playing
king is gonna play whatever he's gonna
play man like that's
their their output
i think at some point maybe not maybe
not today but at some point added we
gotta like
i think we should do like a mock outline
for like 2023
and you know up until like 2025 because
whether with the new studio or with the
new publisher acquisition in activision
man they got all that coming in and they
you know the other studios that they
have working on the games that they have
with the four studios that they
purchased with the initiative we waiting
on perfect dog from them with all of
that
just being there like
i said it i'm not saying a few months
ago i said yo if you're not subscribed
to game pass they've really given you a
reason to i said this back in the
summertime
but now
you know i feel like there's no reason
why you shouldn't be especially after
the activision deal go through like
that's that's something crazy all right
so i i want to kind of like go down a
little bit more towards the rabbit hole
of call of duty because i feel like call
of duty easy
is a okay
let's talk let's leave call of duty for
last when it comes to activision let's
talk about
they get activision
what do you personally want them to do
with it
well i mean
people have been floating around the
idea of having call of duty come out
once every
two or three years right
ah no no i i still think you you have a
is it sledgehammer whoever whoever the
it was the treyarch you have treyarch
treyarch infinity war
ball i think bo the bob's people help
or or the raven team helps one of the
they both might help at this point and
then it's sledgehammer so there's three
core studios
and then there's support studios that
help those three studios i thought
sledgehammer got merged into one of them
am i wrong on that i don't i do remember
okay so that that i do remember hearing
um i'll say this
if i'm there my call of duty every other
year or and they have one continued work
one continuous multiplayer and what i
would do is i'll put the multiplayer
everywhere i put the multiplayer on ps5
or playstation consoles i'll put the
other one on
well that nintendo but
i would i would have
the multiplayer
just component keep going like if
they're going for micro transactions
which they would i would have them keep
doing that um as far as these support
studios high noon and and all the other
ones who are really giving support
i'd actually pull them from that i would
have them work on their own thing
because you you literally could have
something new
from activision at that point wouldn't
that be technically like the multiplayer
thing technically be their br that's
going on uh the war zone
because we're just gonna keep that on
everything
now
well i don't know how long boyz is
always going to last that's why i said
that's why i said if you make a new
multiplayer you make something new but
you know you you keep it and that's what
you would keep on everything i don't
know how how long warzone had um
i don't know how long warzone intended
to last does that make sense i i think
war zone is going to be for the facebook
future now someone did in the chat said
uh raven works on war zones so i guess
they have a whole studio worked on
nothing but war zone um
you know would be cool and what would
really stink people warzone's going to
be on everything i don't think there's a
scenario this deal that goes through
that war zone isn't on everything
so i think we can all assume that war
zone will still be on the playstation
prime regardless what happens to the
yearly installments warzone stay on
there but i got i got something
i got i got i got something that
microsoft can do to put that little
steam
to the playstation consumer when they
play warzone we all know war zones
across play right
ones if you get killed by an xbox user
that's got a spartan suit on
okay
oh i'm laughing at two things laughing
at you laughing with you rather
and uh shout out to the irishman
so i went to jazz's uh tweets and i saw
something but i think jess was just
joking around he says um
he said he says i can confirm that
shh strap no nick i don't know who that
is uh shrapnel next
rumor about um it's about another xbox
franchise getting the master chief
collection treatment
and this blinks the time sweeper all
right look man
it should by the way it should but i
think you i think jazz was joking when
he said that who would who was shrapnel
nick who who was this guy who was this
gentleman does does that name sound
familiar
i don't know who he is
okay go find that xbox error all right
all right i think it was joker by the
way i think it was just joking around i
think it was being a little
you know i think he was trying being a
little facetious that's all
um birthday surprise
we got 315 people in here hit that like
button you guys hit that like button
um
okay let's let's pull this back a little
bit i got another question for you
hustle
how do you feel
about
activision still forcing all their
studios to make call of duty like if
this one particular choice was let's say
that you an executive and you went there
and they say yo hustle
what should we do with the call of duty
franchise because you got to keep in
mind it makes a lot of money it's
like people react like so microsoft
could just easily say don't make a call
of duty every year knowing how much
money call of duty's making
so i would say this if if the ball was
in my court on that one
yeah as a business as a businessman um
we definitely making call of duty every
year
now i'll say this to to avoid like
creative burnout
you
you kind of have it the way how it would
flip between the studios but what i
would do is i would have the best studio
and everybody who wanted to work on call
of duty i would have them work on it and
i would have different support studios
come in every either every other year or
every other term just to be like if
you're not working on this
new project
well you know because you know you can
send like a part of your team over if
you got 200 like a 200 person studio you
could send like like 20 of them over to
be like hey y'all work on this for a
little bit and we'll still work on like
i don't know fable five i'm just putting
the game out there we'll work on like
fable five and then when the thing is
wrapped up with call of duty i'll come
back over and then we finish up i would
have different studios just you know and
just interchange them you know but i
would have the best call through the
studio you know by the people's choice
of course i would have the best studio
always work on that um
in the perfect world i would you know
put people in and out like hey did you
always want to work on this and if they
say yeah then in the perfect world
that's what we do but
i would
you gotta keep just
then i said like 20 million and this is
like an off year for call of duty i'm
like what are we talking about that's
money though like
okay it is that's money man like you got
to get that um especially especially if
they're thinking what i'm thinking and
they're gonna make call of duty
exclusive i think y'all i don't think
you spend that type of money
68.7 billion dollars and that make it
exclusive that's that's just my this is
my thoughts and opinions though here's
what i would do i would
not make it yearly i would take infinity
war and treyarch because those are the
two
most
beloved call of duty studios developers
and i would let them continue and i
would take sledgehammer and put them on
warzone and i would let raven and bob
work on new ips or maybe let bob make a
banjo-kazooie or something like that i
don't know
um and i but i would hit everyone up
that works on call of duty and say look
all of our studios are hiring because
that's usually the point the case
they're all hollering
i would try to be as vocal as possible
when it comes to
um
you know remote
we have a lot of positions in other
country and other companies that you can
work remote from
and i would be switching developers as
much as they want to switch after a game
i wouldn't let people just switch for no
reason you know what i'm saying
but i feel like if you constantly let
these developers stretch their creative
freedom
and get that creative itch i feel like
you'll keep your talent longer
yeah and it's just like you know you get
infinity war you get treyarch you tell
everyone in the company
we have call of duty infinity war and
treyarch we need these on two to three
year rotations probably three would be
best
so you would have a call of duty
every like two years uh because they're
both making them i don't know i don't
know how they knew that goes so
then you would have sledgehammer and
they would be nothing but dedicated to
warzone and to make war zone functions
correctly and then you would have bob do
whatever they want to do
because
the call of duty's got to come out
frequently but i do think that they
don't have to come out yearly
because i personally feel like
if you let call of duty breathe
and it comes out every other year
i think it would actually sell better
because you had people miss it for a
year
yeah and you know but you're constantly
throwing out that war zone info you know
what i'm saying that war zone stuff you
could you could have since they since
they'll be owned by microsoft you could
call over to 343 have a halo
event where you know just for that one
particular thing they're dropping down
on halo maps and using halo weapons for
an event you know what i'm saying
now that will be doped it's like a i
don't know if you heard of this movie uh
addict is called six degrees of
separation but now but it's christopher
bacon thing but
yeah having all of those different
worlds interact with one another like
that that'll be super dope um behave in
the chat i'm i'm watching the chat y'all
behaving in chat yeah i act like i got
some sense
moving on
moving on y'all chill jesus yes
i i'm looking at them unless they get
too out of hand
um
imagine hey playing
war zone and they have an event
where you're being you're dropping down
on reach
and you can like pick up a battle rifle
a covenant weapon
and i feel like stuff like that would
energize it and it would make up for the
for the for the for the non-yearly call
of duties you know what i'm saying
oh yeah
yeah and while you're getting yourself
like you gather yourself yeah like
having those like special like types of
features um
i wanted to see that in gears 5 as a
matter of fact when i mean it was
rumored at the at that point in time but
perfect dark is being remade as we all
know i did want to see joanna dog run
around with marcus phoenix and the rest
of them i didn't want to see like a
battle told running around with the best
of them with the rest of them rather um
in gears 5 in that multiplayer because
like it didn't really make because it
don't really matter you can even have
killer instant characters in there
because it don't really matter like it's
just multiplayer that's not anything
that you would take serious um and if
you want like more casual market you can
always do that now for tournament mode
of course you turn all that off and you
know you get busy but like yeah but this
is just a regular [ __ ] casual mode
yeah like throw everybody in there if
you got if you got the you know
if you have the time and the manpower um
i've noticed that you know other people
from other studios will go help out
other people like help out like
microsoft what's up i do think with all
these companies that microsoft's owning
some of these companies
activision are not activision
they might have to get sacrificed to be
a sports studio because
i do think we're getting to the point
where there's so many studios
there needs to be like four support
studios that do nothing but help the
other 36 you know what i'm saying like
yeah um
yo this
that's 30 36
by the way 36 studios
like come on man it might be 36. i'm
pretty sure it's it's it's in the middle
well i'm thinking i don't know why i'm
thinking 30 i don't know why i'm
thinking 32 but i might be wrong it
might be 32. it might be 32. but it's
still over 30 dog like
microsoft don't need to buy nothing else
if we really want to take it there but
yeah i get it i get it i mean you know
like i but i feel like some of those
support studios who will be support
studios
i kind of feel like they're going to get
their own like i said i think i said it
on iop how noon is going to get the
shot and the opportunity to make their
own thing what i would do because i do
think you want to give them their own
opportunities to not be a support studio
you have let's say
support studio 50 support studio of a
hundred i don't know what kind of
support studios i have you have like
a core
team and a support team like you got 20
people that's working on
smaller titles a smaller title something
like a bleeding edge just give you like
a scale of a game and then the rest are
helping other studios with doing
whatever they need to that way you're
still getting some kind of output from
them
and you're giving them the opportunity
to prove that you know this course these
core
groups they can make good games and you
know maybe you can actually give people
the opportunity
to go out because i do feel like if you
make a studio be nothing but a support
studio a lot of those developers might
be unhappy because they're not working
on anything they're out so that's why i
feel like yeah that's why i feel like
have a core team in the support studios
that make a smaller title and then the
rest of the studio does nothing but help
other
studios how this is going to work out
this is a
this is a this isn't an undertaking to
say the least um i know it's not going
to all fall on matt booty or anything
but that's
that's still a lot that he has to manage
and you know even though activation can
kind of
police themselves they can't really
police themselves if we you know know
what's been going on with them anyway it
can't really police themselves so a
whole new management team is probably
going to be put in place so that's and
that's definitely something different
man and i know and a lot of people don't
agree with this but i do feel like
there's a very good chance
that sarah bond goes to activision like
i i think there's a good chance and
people keep saying that people saying oh
they're um
mr iceman of the two super chat let high
moon finish their transformer trilogy i
don't know enough about transformers i
didn't play their games but you know
what mr uh irishman if you want that man
let me let high moon finish a
transformers trilogy
so
i personally
what what eddie did you want to get a
dragon hot yobi's uh oh i didn't even
see anything um can you read it i don't
see it
yes okay so dragon heart yobe it's my
boy right there he is he has been a
member for seven months let me
i gotta move everything
all right there we go
um
peace love life i kind of wish i would
have came up with that saying peace love
life i'll pee and my boy hustling
motivate his greatness keep shining
uh keep trying to keep working
um working on
whoa am i yo i'm not [ __ ] oh no i
can't see hold on hold on hold on we're
gonna move it over i just refreshed i
see it oh thank god
this is his greatness keep shining and
working on your legacy man and epic tell
it shall be respect what it was is like
i had the thing at the very top so i
didn't see that yeah i was getting my
little rant man uh boom i'm in the way
let me get this uh let me get this one
real quick before we move on we gotta
find out the super giraffe from space
delta king dovel height king i don't
know man we're gonna move past it
atvi has more studios inside the main
studios i think there's plenty of
support studios atv has around 10k
employees i don't know what that is uh
yeah what is that so definitely you
don't have to super chat man yeah go
ahead and try to google that if they
have 10 000 employees and that's a
support studio then microsoft never has
to do anything else that that's a lot of
people i don't know i'm not educating
that matter so i don't really know
what's active no that's the reverend
abbreviation for activision blizzard but
okay
yeah that's the abbreviation for active
well hold on i put in atv
i got actively active vision blizzard
incorporated
he might be just saying that it's just
all the studios combined
all right
look
i personally feel like microsoft has
something here and i think that
you don't have to
you know
do a lot of things you just need to
really just be very vocal when it comes
to
what you're going to do with these ips
like
once the deal was made like kind of like
they did with
with
bethesda
but i really do want a year and a half
of just waiting like
oh that's so frustrating we have to wait
this long again to find out this info
oh my god but i i think you know even if
worst case scenario call of duty is an
exclusive is not an exclusive but day
and date on game pass i feel like that's
a good
that's a good
worst case scenario like here's the
thing chat here's the thing hustle
i personally feel like if it is an ex a
multi-plat and it's day on game pass
i firstly think that's eventually that's
like poking you every year hustle your
sony i microsoft every time call of duty
comes out your fans got to pay 60 70
and my people just got to be part of the
subscription service every november it
comes out poking you hustle next
november i'm poking you hustle and then
all of your fans every year is like
yo man that game pass over there looking
real fine and eventually they end up
moving because they're call of duty
players so why keep doing the
like investing the worst
that's just my opinion so let's
let's go to call of duty clearly call of
duty's big everyone's talking about call
of duty
hustle how you think they're gonna move
with call of duty
honestly
um but i know because we just spoke
about it i i think they they they put it
out i think they have i think they would
have to put it out every year if they
just spent the amount of money that they
spend there maybe they're not looking to
recoup the 68 that sound crazy when i
say that maybe that they're not looking
to recoup the 68.7 billion dollars but
conventional thinking
just small thinking you put it out every
year
i think
i think you would have to
i think you got to put it out every year
as far as that um
i know a lot of people
that's because there's no wasn't just
your pack podcast was listening to it's
just a lot of different podcasts oh
they're gonna put out call of duty every
you know once every two or three years
we don't know that
we don't know that and honestly i guess
the more i'm just thinking about it
look you can have a ubisoft situation
right the way absence will make the
heart grow fonder with um the last
assassin's creed i do believe it's the
highest selling assassin's creed this is
after they took like that year break or
two-year break
with the with the assassin's creed is it
vikings
yeah um assassin's creed van gaal
valhalla thank you thank you apparently
that's the highest selling one i did a
little research on that that's the
highest one so maybe it's a good thing
but honestly man like it bring in so
much bread though i i
i don't think i can picture it i don't
think i can picture there's a there's a
moment in time to where they let that
happen i don't think so
here's how i feel about it i feel like
if if they continue to let call of duty
bu
every year it's come
every studio is making call of duty
uh if it's exclusive
if it's a multi-plat
it's every year if exclusive i don't
think it's every year
uh because personally
being
a game that comes out yearly i don't
think it makes sense for a multiplayer
that doesn't make sense for
a yearly game
because
if you're a yearly game you you you got
to internally
check where other stuff's coming from
like you're not just a studio that can
just deliver anytime you want like you
have to maintain a certain map you have
to maintain certain things and i feel
like if they're coming out yearly that
doesn't make sense activision being by
themselves makes sense to make every
studio make call of duty
as an xbox studio and as a as as a
platform holder it doesn't make sense to
have
three or four of your developers
studios making call of duty year round
you know what i'm saying
because that doesn't seem business
wise to me sure they might make some
money but i feel like they might make
more money off of doing
things when it comes to having them make
new ips
someone keeps saying we got a super
check shreyer's tweet someone keeps
saying that's what i'm doing now that's
what i'm doing let me get this super
chat while you do that uh five dollar
super chat from pixel pit g
schreier reports that call of duty's and
contacts to sony until 2023 and that's
it also microsoft financial year begins
in july 2022.
deal can close this year actually
and then two dollar super chat says
check the new try or tweet
okay so i did that's
that's a whole article i would have to
read but
if you know cause i'm thinking that deal
was longer than that first and foremost
so maybe that's why jim ryan came out
pardon me i mean that's why jim ryan
came out and was like
what y'all gonna do you know with call
of duty now so so that deal was expiring
quicker than we thought
um
you know i always thought those deals
were longer than that too but you know
what do i know right
damn that's okay
huh
i kind of want to see 20 so 2023 is the
the last one for war zone 2.
he said after that it's hazy okay okay
okay um
oh
i think with that knowledge um
i just went ahead and retweeted it
yeah i'm looking at it now
i think with that knowledge
well
we said it was gonna be exclusive but
now i look like it's going to be in
school some sooner than we thought
um
i mean kind of with that being said i i
think that i think they still should put
it out every year
even if they make it exclusive they
probably won't but i think they should
that
the only way i could see them doing that
is they make
they make two teams in uh
infinity war
and two uh two teams uh in that and
treyarch and both teams are making a
call of duty simultaneously you know
what i'm saying like i just personally
don't see
the point of us
of five four to five studios
all making call of duty regardless if
they're not all making core call of
duties they're still making some form of
call of duty's they're neither assisting
making call of duty they're making war
zone
i don't see microsoft where it makes
sense that all of them are making call
of duty like as far as a content wise
because microsoft wants as much content
out as possible i don't necessarily
think microsoft wants a bunch of call of
duty's out you know what i'm saying like
as far as it's a multi-plat it makes
more sense to have those game all those
studios being making games year-round
but to me call is call of duty strong
enough
to buy
something for 68 billion dollars just to
continue to use all of those studios to
make that one
franchise
when you use how much money you make
yeah i mean that that's true that that's
definitely true
but me personally as as a gamer
i would want them to
make have the highest people make call
of duty and the rest be doing something
different uh we got a two dollar trip
from uh w rey
butchered it
we're holding on to that do you think
sony will start uh will start will still
hold the marketing um
they pay for yeah if they pay for it
right is long
as long as they have marketing uh these
these deals i think they will keep the
marketing
but the moment that those deals are up
that's a wrap microsoft's never going to
let sony market that game ever
like that is
through the moment that's over
unless they pay like their way and then
it's not gonna be it's not gonna be cool
for playstation if they if they're
paying that much bread no no once uh i
didn't think it was gonna be over that
quick i'm thinking 20 2024 2025 like
when i'm thinking because i always
thought you know half the generation is
kind of like kind of kind of how that
worked but
generations changed anyway um
yeah so
uh that they they definitely won't have
the market and all the stuff is gonna be
yo listen i can't wait to see them
commercials the way he says plays best
on xbox series x play you can play it
for well not for free you can play it
for
ten dollars on game pass pc don't you
know y'all know those commercials coming
right i'm just saying y'all spending
that type of brand without promoting it
so we got a two dollar superstar from
infinity k uh kod uh kok uh d okay
uh that was that was uh that was a dumb
moment on my part but more than 20
million players for halo infinite that's
that's a huge number and i actually kind
of expect that now let's talk about call
of duty in terms of
i wonder if it's against the marketing
is even if sony's marketing the game
can microsoft if they own the company at
that time
let's say it gets done before the next
call of duty like
it's it's internally done but they
haven't announced it i wonder if they
can do some
some stuff on the back end
to get call of duty on game pass day and
date
huh
i
you know what honestly i don't know
because that because when you say you
have to honor your contractual
obligations
that sounds like you can't really do
that so whatever you had in place
beforehand
it sounds like it's already
what those contracts say if it
says that you can't put nothing in a
subscription service which we have been
told that sony was starting to
you know do deals like that but the
thing is is apparently they made these
deals in 2016.
that's when they did this deal that was
kind of before game pass started like
really getting some traction and i don't
think sony really would have had
anything to worry about when it come to
game pass because it's call of duty they
never expected microsoft to ever buy
this kind of company so kind of makes me
think that maybe sony didn't go back and
redo any type of verbiage with those
with those contracts because maybe
internally sony thought that that would
never be an issue
i mean hey uh when game pass first
started i didn't think it was going to
be as successful well maybe not
successful but as popular as it is now
so
i'm sure i'm sure
that the team over there sony whoever's
over there playstation whoever was
overseeing that i'm sure they had their
lawyers look at that i'm
because at that point you got to cross
your t's and that's your eyes you got to
make sure
it's like murphy's law whatever can
happen will happen then i think in this
case i i think they got that sewn up so
i don't think we
i don't think we see any um i don't
think we see anything different come out
of those contracts i think they honor
those contracts first and it if it is
until in the 2023 like the tweet from
jason's trying to suggest i want to make
sure i read that article before i really
put it out
if that is anything to go by then you
won't even have to worry about it too
long like 2024 for sure
at the sound of what i just read
then you'll be i and um hey now lives
okay cause i don't think you're the
first person maybe you no you're not the
first person you wanna win a soldier
where y'all getting that information
about halo
someone because that uh someone super
chatted earlier so that that's out there
all right so why don't we wait for them
why we wait for them
let me ask you a question
what is your opinion when people are on
twitter
saying that microsoft
shouldn't be buying publishers and what
is your opinion on
the
adjacent of the scale saying that sony
does nothing but nurture studios before
they buy them so what what is your
opinion on this matter because it's been
a matter for a while where people say
microsoft doing nothing but buy studios
they're not really having a mindset with
them which i do think there is some kind
of valid truth to that like i think
microsoft they have an idea of what they
want to do with us with a company like
activision but as far as like sitting
down and having a road map or something
i don't know if they have that you know
what i'm saying um and then you got sony
uh sony part of the scale where people
are saying sony does nothing but nurture
studios from the ground up for years of
working with the making second party
studios and then
they acquire them sooner or later how do
you feel about these adjacent arguments
that people are saying microsoft is
doing more harm to the industry because
they're buying these massive publishers
and they're consolidating the industry
more and more
according to
sony that they're just buying students
that they work with
all right
let me address uh playstation nurturing
talent first with a playstation shout
out to them because they are nurturing
talent you you have like a studio like
insomniac right
had them for so long they thought the
great grass was green enough no pun
intended on the other side over here
micros we'll say over here but over at
microsoft or over xbox it did sunset
overdraft it was cool but you know at
the end of the day you know sony picked
them up for 229 million dollars
spider-man
out of here spider-man is doing what it
does and insomnia is probably like the
premier studio over there as far as
nurturing talent and working with talent
for such a long time
that's good on playstations part cause
they can get everything for the low
they don't get the money that microsoft
guy microsoft um and i'll use the sports
analogy here shout out to anybody from
the dmv
microsoft and the way that they're
moving with the money
they're kind of like daniel snyder from
the washington football team i do
typically in sports when you just buy
and buy and buy and buy and buy sure you
may have on paper you might have
the best talent
regardless but you know in sports
you typically will fall flat on your
face in the nba you have to build up
through the draft and you know once you
build up to the draft you can win
championships
for the most part you might have a
lebron situation the way you can put
talents together and you can win a
couple championships right
but a lot of times it doesn't work out
in your favor
colin had actually mentioned this
yesterday i'm cool with sony nurturing
talent that's the one of the first
things i said the cognito i was like oh
from microsoft but this was long before
this this mavic last time he was on with
us i said yo what they should do is
nurture talent but they're not in the
best they can't wait to nurture talent
so they got to make these acquisition
deals um and i do want to stay for the
record if sony had the bread that
microsoft had to spend
i mean we we'd see that from them too
for the record we would definitely see
that from them too but
i would say
is the consolidation thing a problem
yeah and it's not just for physical
media like i've been trying to hammer
home this whole whole entire podcast but
it's going to be an issue a little bit
later like
attic let's say we live in a world where
xbox is running microsoft would run in
there right
playstation this is the shell of the
former self nintendo 2 right
everything's on game pass we can't get
nothing physical we can't get no
physical games right
what happens if god forbid what happens
if i get kicked off of
what's this
game pass let's say if i get kicked off
because i get banned from it i mean
everything that i've purchased in there
i can't get it normal like
my fear of consolidation comes with
stuff like that like not from cheating
or nothing like that but like it could
be a freak accident the way somebody can
hack my account and then
go off with it and there's no more
hustling to motivate and i'm that
entitled to the games that i already
paid for like the that's one of my
biggest concerns about like
consolidation in the industry and if i'm
speaking a little out of turn you know
y'all in the chat let me know of course
but just let me know from that off a
little bit
i feel like
i understand where people come when it
comes to consolidation
i don't think it's activision because
here's the thing
i feel like there
if you have everyone under one roof it's
hard for people to really innovate
because everyone has the same mentality
so it's hard to really go something
different because everyone has the same
thought process
i don't think that's the case with
activision because i feel like
activisions had years to improve their
brands and they still haven't done it
you know instead of
hiring more people to do more
stuff in individual studies like an
infinity war making two call of duty's
at the same time
they
chose to make other studios they own
make call of duty
they've chose to
completely crash wow because people say
that wild's been going downhill
uh overwatch is isn't a mess right now
we don't know what's going to happen
with that and i feel like the more up
the more things i give you
do we really and then not to mention
the disgusting stuff that's going on in
the actual building
it's been going on for years
hustle do you honestly feel like it's
ever going to change unless someone
takes over that company
no
it wouldn't have changed if if microsoft
wouldn't pick them up um but i think it
and i think well here's the thing i
think it would have changed but it would
have probably been to the detriment of a
lot of people
going around um a lot of people just in
gaming in general um and i think that's
the reason why bobby carter codec
whatever his name is that's why he went
to uh microsoft in the first place
i think that he knew that what's up i
think he went to microsoft because
he knew that
there's a big hole
and he knew that he couldn't fix it
alone
um
he
he gonna take his here's the thing
people say oh he's gonna take his 300
million dollars and walk into the sunset
regardless what happens to this man go
parachute or not he's fine i can assure
you
there's no way this man doesn't have a
nest egg somewhere in the cayman islands
or something
this man has plenty of money without
that 300 million dollars he was going to
be fine regardless but
my thing
is i'm okay
with giving this man 300 million dollars
to save the rest of them you know what
i'm saying like because it's just like
when you're in that kind of position
that he's in it's not easy to get rid of
you
he's pretty much gotta willingly
willingly go because he's the ceo you
know what i'm saying
i'm sure he can get voted off or
something
but it's like at the end of the day
i'm okay with the way things are going
because
they're clearly not going to fix it on
their own someone else has got to come
in and fix it
so
we got a five dollar superchat from cmat
activision blizzard has
480 million active users
once the deal closes if microsoft
converts 10 percent and has 70
million uh subscribers by 12 31 23 is
getting past then a success
i'm gonna get back to that
we got a ten dollar super chat from uh
harsh kisky
you know you know what
judy target
you know
i'm gonna butcher that before you even
did that
uh turn 10 initiative coalition 343 made
by xbox nurtured playground games undead
labs crystal t
oh my god the devs aren't just waiting
for a call from xbox not easy to grow
which is why sony is buying studios too
100 agree with you i don't think was
ever really saying that microsoft's not
nurturing studios either um but because
i personally feel like
bethesda
is the defined thing of perching when
fallout 76 failed do you remember the
first thing todd howard said he called
phil spencer he called football
so clearly they've nurtured them too
they literally helped get morrowind on
the xbox platform they've been there
with with
that company this entire time
so i want to go back to the previous one
cmat he said activision has 480 million
active users let's talk about that for a
second i don't think you're going to be
able to convert people so easily
but they have something called wow and a
wow subscription service
i get it they're going to make a lot of
money off wow regardless what they do
but what happens if they merge wow
with gamepad subscription
because you're gonna get those people
regardless but you know what's good a
lot of people such as myself will
unsubscribe to services like that when
the game is no longer providing me
anything and i don't want to play wow
anymore you know what i'm saying
but if
y was just a perk of game pass to get
into the game
and then after
you you've had your fill of wow
then you could just turn on
you know whatever they do with the xbox
game pass if you have an xbox you just
turn on your xbox and you have access to
this library on top of all that
i feel like
you could keep people in that
subscription service longer so instead
of losing five to ten percent of your
subscriber base yearly and then they
come back eventually six months later
you could keep them all damn year long
you know what i'm saying
yep
um i'm gonna ask the cmad so well
possibly or try to answer she met a
super chat
well we can't really answer that because
we don't really know what their goal is
a lot of people say 50 million
game past subscribers as they go if that
is they're going to hit 70 million
obviously that's what they want to do
but um
that
that's it's going to be a tad bit
difficult like as we know right now game
pass is at 25 million subscribers i
don't really think
we covered that so much i think you guys
covered them on iop i'm not exactly sure
but that's a very telling number too
25 million regardless of you got it off
the back of a box of cheetos snickers
bag of chips i don't care how you got it
there's still 25 million people who can
experience
i don't get the wolf for the first time
if you ain't on it like that
all of the first party ips like if
you're not playing well halo's free to
play so i kind of don't want to put halo
on there even though halo infinite is
there but you can play halo for the
first time you can it's a lot that you
can do for the very first time
or you know just oh go ahead and relive
some classics like i'm trying to do
right you can do that for the very first
time through game pass and i think
that's dope but i if if you're asking me
70 million
at ten dollars you say ten dollars right
yeah oh addict
i think they do roll in the wild
subscription and to game pass too which
which would lead to a price increase in
my opinion this is i think it's going to
do the same thing i i do think it'll
eventually to a crisis and priest but i
don't think it will be immediately
yeah yes it's going to be a little
minute um what was the other thing xbox
games would you know how games would go
kind of like wrote itself in for game
pass
they're going to make you get off all
that stuff and just subscribe to game
pace
and it'll probably at some point i'll
give it a couple years it'll probably
like 20 a month or something and i don't
really think that you can argue
with 15 a month and i don't think that
you could argue any i don't think you
can really argue if it's because it's 15
for gamepad's ultimate i think gamepad's
ultimate on pcn console is going to go
across the board and i don't really
think you can argue that price either by
the way because it's 10 right now for me
on pc if they charge me an extra five
dollars considering they got all this
new stuff coming in i can't really be
too
i wouldn't be too hurt by it i guess
this is what i'm trying to say yeah i
think the point of the wow scenario
is that if they're over there just
playing wow and then they get bored
and then they just unsung to while
you're not getting their money
but if they're playing well and wow is
part of game pass and no longer its own
subscription that and keep in mind
that's what i'm saying it's got to be
in game pass you have to subscribe to
game pass to get access to wow
and then after you're done with wow you
go over there you know you play halo you
play sea of thieves you play and then
you're spending money because keep in
mind these wild people are the type of
people to buy micro transactions so if
you put them on another game
you're gonna get them buying [ __ ] there
too
and i think that's the point someone did
bring up you know put the elder scrolls
online fallout 76 in that i think that's
already in a game pass isn't it like you
get game pass you have access to those
games i don't know
not i don't play those games
um but you know that's just my opinion
when it comes to that yeah you know i
kind of want to move on because we been
on this a little bit and you guys know
go watch the last iop you could see
six and a half hours of content on this
activision thing
so we're going to uh move on to the
plans for 2022
i'm going to be talking from
gaming addicts what games i i'm looking
forward to and i'm going to be talking a
little bit about iron lord's podcast not
a whole lot because if i'd be given too
many bars on the future of iop cognito
will literally shut my internet off
oh man
so hustle you go first what is your
goals for 2022 as a content creator and
what's some games that you really
looking forward to playing
all right well i'll answer the the
latter first because that's that's
pretty simple for me
horizon zero dawn is coming out um but
before that friday right i'll say
horizontal horizon forbidden west excuse
me but friday as y'all know i'm the
uncharted fan so
i'm trying to lose legacy is dropping
this friday so i'll be playing that one
what sir on what oh playstation oh
that's right playstation 5 indeed uh so
you don't want to play it on pc
not well not yet i'm just going to get
it on ps5 see how the performance is see
if it you know see if it goes at 60 plus
frames a second but we'll see but i want
to see if there are drastic improvements
there i still have um i guess there must
be in my closet or something but i still
got part four and i still have lost
legacy on ps4 so i do want to go back
and forth between just to you know i'm
not gonna do a comparison video but i
want to see i just want to see if there
are differences there that warrants a 50
purchase as opposed to i think you get
it for ten dollars uh ten dollars a
piece for both of those games now um so
i just want to see differences there um
i am getting on pc because you know i
got to um
as far as my plans for 2022 obviously
be here every tuesday
i want to stream on twitch at least
three times a week at the very least um
i got a show on production that you and
i spoke about
back behind the scenes that i will
execute sometime later on this year i'm
just waiting on like an artist and i'm
just waiting on like a theme song so i
kind of got some stuff away in the tuck
if i could uh do anything like for real
it's honestly just stream on as far as
my youtube is concerned and shout out to
y'all who subscribed to me yesterday
when i was on um or the day before
yesterday when i was on iop i really
appreciate that support so with that
being said
two times a week try to put a video out
whether it's the live stream in terms of
the thing that i'm working on or just
the actual video in terms of like a lot
of the retro stuff that i'm doing or
just character developments that i also
want to get into i want to cover that
most of this year be here of course
um
jump on you know different podcasts
which i plan on doing it's just
i'm ironing out of situations of a few
deals at the moment um just personal
stuff that i'm ironing at the moment so
i'll be around
i'm just gonna go harder than i went
last year and it seems like i'm gonna
have the freedom to do so so i'm just
gonna go hard man i'm just gonna live
with my namesake
i hear that man
so um they want to know what your
channel is so put that now uh in the uh
alrighty the chat while we talk so
here's okay so for
me
i want to grow more on social media in
general like
put more on tick tock et cetera et
cetera i actually want to
start
putting more emphasis behind in in terms
of our iron english podcast uh we want
to start getting more unique people on
the channel uh on the on the podcast on
the show uh i'd like actually more
i'd like to have more people in the
industry i kind of really want to target
voice actors
because i feel like they don't be on
shows a whole whole lot so we're going
to really focus on that hopefully well
i'm going to reach out to certain people
on that i i personally want to grow our
twitch channel
a lot more i do want to grow our twitch
channel i'm thinking i'm going to like
the chat tell me how you feel about this
thought process i would like to start
doing
a twitch stream
two hours before iop
so pretty much oh no we go 1 p.m
i would like to do like a post twitch
stream
at like 10
or 11 probably 11 or 10 10 10 30 11. you
guys get what i'm saying it's just you
know
can i give you a piece of advice what
don't do it
unless i mean unless you're comfortable
with it because you will get burnt out
like i know it's i'll tell you just from
experience personal experience it's hard
to joke on both youtube and twitch
and i'll just leave it at that this is
just gonna be something you know for
people
that are waiting for the show you can
jump on
enjoy what do you mean like a pre oh
like a pre-show yeah it's not gonna be
iron lords related it's just going to be
you know
you could go there chill into the actual
show starts and then what i would do is
i would end it at like
12 12 30ish and then i would do the
background stuff to make sure it's
launched in with the actual show so i
think i'm going to do something like
that i don't know what i'm going to do
that because i got to talk to people
about that
i do want to re-do the attic show uh i
do want to i'm going to start
looking into doing an intro with our own
music instead of using the iop music i
don't know i'm going gonna do that yet
um i don't know i'm gonna do the intro i
do want an overlay
that looks nice besides these black bars
up here down here and up here i think
they look kind of bad
um so pretty much like what i want is
like
rotating design up here i want our
social media down here somewhere
uh and then i want like
i got ideas with that but i don't just
want this overlay because i want to be a
show that we visually show you what
we're talking about a lot so if we're
talking about a certain subject
i can bring something and show you why
we're doing it so like what i want to do
eventually is
i want to be able to press a button
on my stream deck and instead of us
being like here where
he's on the left i'm on the right or
vice versa i don't know what we are now
we'll switch to like up here to like
right here
and then there would be
whatever we're talking about will be on
the right it'll be the same overlay it's
just will be slightly different
on it so and i want it to look really
nice
really professional
um you know and then i might have one
that there's just
i'm going to gameplay talking to people
throughout the next couple weeks
you know and that's what i'm going to
really focus on there i'm going to focus
on reviews as well
i'm going to really dig into reviews i'm
not going to review everything that
comes out i'm going to review
dying light 2 i'm going to review
probably not destiny because i'm going
to leave cognito for that because
destiny is more of his lane and i'm
probably going to review horizon
but i'm probably not going to review
eldon ring because i'm going to be
playing horizon and it's not that i
can't play them both because i'm pretty
sure i'm going to be able to play them
both i'm going to be
burnt out by the time eldon ring comes
out
so if eldon ring does come out i will be
reviewing it it's just not going to be
fast unless i get a review copy
which you know we are more access to
cert that's why i like microsoft buying
stuff because we do have a microsoft
connect that you know does
give us um you know emails and we can
ask him for stuff depending on the
demand we might get it we might not get
it
that's not easy to get everywhere else
so the more stuff microsoft buys the
more access i get so i'm okay with that
but you know i'm gonna reach out to
other people i'm gonna try to do more
addict
show collabs like get your favorite
content creators that don't have a huge
following and have more of a focus on
them
and i'm also going to focus on getting
better content creators in general uh on
it as well so it's just going to be me
and hustle
but i am going to try like two times a
month
to bring once a month to bring a big
content creator that we can bounce ideas
off of and once a month to get a smaller
contractor that we can elevate up uh so
that's that's the goal i don't know if
that's gonna happen but that's the goal
but you know i appreciate everyone for
coming through here uh you know we had
up to like 350-ish
i can't hey hey are we leaving
no no not yet it's just okay i i i'm
thinking because we still we still got
to do the uh the games that we look
forward to and we still got to do
new vegas uh i mean the new star wars
games i just want to thank everyone
for
iop sunday
because
that was big and you guys came in big
for that there was 1900 people in that
chat at one time
you guys don't understand how big that
was for us and i want to thank every
last one of you that was in that show
even somebody that was hitting on my
girlfriend we won't go into that
but it is what it is uh but you know
what games are you looking forward to
hustle uh we'll go with three three
games this year that you're looking
forward to playing
ooh i can give you two but horizon
forbidden west horizon forbidden west
for sure
um i say two the reason why i said i
give you two because we don't know if
god or war
ragnarok is coming out this year they
say it is if it is i'll put it there and
um
if you know me
my heart is with the the teenage mutant
ninja turtles so uh teenage mutant ninja
turtles shredders revenge just probably
that's that's the one that i'm looking
forward the most to actually um i don't
know if it has online co-op yet we will
have to see nickelodeon.emu and i think
somebody else is working with this too
but that's the biggest one that i'm
looking forward to the the the quick
little 16-bit joint that's that's the
quickest one that i'm looking forward to
man um but as far as those games that's
it for now
um what else what else comes out this
year i know starfield comes out this
year i'm interested to take a look at it
i'll you know game pass it and just just
to see but um you know
but that's the stuff ain't really ain't
really my cup of tea i'll try it though
i'll try it though i'm looking forward
to starfield dying light too
and
i want to say eldon ring
oh man all right
so i'm gonna say eldon ring right now i
gotta see more about that game
i'm gonna say eldon ring i think we're
gonna have a good year of gaming like i
think 2022
is going to be a fantastic year of
gaming uh and i'm excited i don't think
god of war is coming out this year i
think there's a very small chance that
that game comes out
uh but you know
i'm looking forward to it so you know
let's move on
to the fact that star wars is being made
exclusively just about
by respawn entertainment well you could
were you surprised by the fact that ea
like the fact
that
star wars battlefront 3 is it coming out
and it looks like
they gave all of those
to respawn you know how much
they liked
the the last game they made i can't
remember what that game was called
the last jedi the
no i think it's fallen order or
something like that
um
that game did so well
i'm gonna own that yeah that game and i
beat it it was a great game fantastic
game they did so well
that they're like
i'm a triple down on respawn i'm gonna
let them make a sequel to that game and
let them make a strategy game and i
think the last one was uh a first person
game i don't know
really we gotta take a moment and
realize
that respawn might be one of the best
most diverse studios out there right now
and we got a five dollar super chat from
our tea or you know i butchered it
already we're going to move past that
not sure if you already went over it
microsoft earnings came out 18 billion
in profits last quarter xbox revenue was
16 to 17 annual growth
that's a lot look man it's
the harness like they're doing great
like for anyone that tries to say
microsoft's not doing great they're just
they're just playing consoles they're
not they're not actually
they're actually caring about the growth
of the industry they just want xbox to
fail
so you know back to to respawn
i think
i think the top five are the best
developers out there right now
i want to see if respawn made um
were these the same people who made apex
legends yes and they made titanfall
oh oh oh oh oh titanfall got a little i
like apex though i love vaper they
haven't missed they have been missed
since they came out
yeah so i i did a little research on
that and i didn't want to make sure i
got the studios right and they did make
um
um fallen order and that's the game that
i do all my own on steam i was i had to
figure like i haven't played it like
that like that that's the dream with
deborah wilson and uh oh buddy from
shameless he also played in gotham he's
the lead role um in it
yeah that game's first person and third
person they're super fun
uh
uh fall in order is a little bit too
hard for me though it was a good game
man i beat it though it was a good game
i liked it hey look man hey look i'm
gonna keep a trail with you doug if if i
if i play it enough i'm sure i can get
deep into it but
it it's a good looking game too let me
let me just say that
it looked really good the voice acting
was on point but that's deborah wilson
and that's the other gentleman from
shameless like i would probably would
expect nothing less
yeah i think the fact that they get
three games and these are going to be
three different types of games too i
think one's gonna be a strategy game
one's gonna be a first person shooter
and
did they say the other one was going to
be a third-person shooter
strategy
uh most likely one of them is the fallen
order sequel
so i would say that third one is
probably going to be their their
try on
on battlefront that's my assumption
um
okay well
we'll see we'll see um i'm i'm only
optimistic about that deal because i do
like apex i do like apex a whole lot um
fun game i just push out like i honestly
wish i had more people to play with and
um i also wish that the ea launcher
wasn't such you know trash
the e is it the one of those ea launches
is absolute garbage addict
yeah oh my oh my god well actually
not to backtrack a little bit we'll
backtrack just for a couple seconds or
you know however long this takes what do
you feel like they need to do a battle
net microsoft with activation
you use it
yeah i think
i think they need to
rip game pass out of the windows store
and surgically put that nice looking way
into the the battlenet and just use
battlenet and i'm sorry i know people
aren't gonna like this next statement i
think they need to rip their games off
of steam and surgically put those games
on battle net because i feel like
windows didn't do it because it was a
bad launcher but people have said
battlenet's a good launcher so i think
if you put those games on battle net
you're going to be fine like i think you
might upset some people i don't know
maybe they want to just
maybe they want to sell it on steam
because they know that there's those
steam fanboys that's going to buy it on
steam because they don't want anything
else so they get they
they get their fruit and they get
everyone else's free so i can understand
they want to do that because if you want
to abuse those pc fanboys do it it's on
me oh man come on well let's not do that
because i definitely game on steam in
here if you want to go out there
and buy a game when it's on game pass on
battle net you deserve to get
manipulated by by steve i'll say this
well hey when i buy a game on steam nine
times out of ten it does work but no
i'll typically try a game on game pass
and if i like it and i'm like all right
cool
i'll just go cop it like i'll just go
buy whatever it is i'm going to try
death store which i think is on pc i'm
going to try that store and i said i
told king i was going to buy it anyway
and i i completely forgot about it i'll
buy sometime this week if i you know if
i play like an hour of it
i'm cool with it like i'm cool with
rebuying that on steam just because i
want a copy of it because i don't think
there is a physical copy of that so i'll
get it on steam man and i'll just have
it there but
yeah yeah yeah you can't don't don't
leave my same little brothers and little
sisters
i just feel like that one of the reasons
that they failed
was because
windows store was so bad it was so bad
but i do feel like when i talk to like
pc
gamers
they don't
they don't hate battle net they just
prefer steam
like for the most part i like
people will go to battle net when they
want to play something
they won't go to windows like seek how
bad windows
windows store is that people just won't
buy they people will go to steam to buy
your stuff at full price rather than use
windows to download your stuff at game
pass part of me feels like that's
intentional but that's just me i don't
know well i feel like i'll tell you
you're a software company you still
ain't fixed your windows store it's
pretty bad yeah and i'll tell you before
we moved on like that's the reason why i
bought gears five on this thing because
as you know it gives four
like it was pretty bad like it wasn't
working with the 10 series cars and i
had a 1080 ti at that time it wasn't
working it wasn't working it wasn't
working on steam and that was just it
probably was a game problem wasn't
working on steam wasn't working in the
microsoft store it wasn't working at all
it's like it was just a thing so but it
kind of it burned me so much because i
spent so much money on my rig at that
point i'm like yo what in the world like
that's like telling my hands up he said
no we just going here now someone said
recall i said why remove from steam when
you own steam in 10 years
there you go that's wild
you know what they could have bought
steam with the money they just bought
activision with
yeah i was gonna say that's not even not
the real amount of the realm of
possibility anymore it's not like it's
funny because you can't even
like what do you say yo
you spent 68.7 billion dollars like what
do you say now like what
how did them conversations go
man look anyway anyway i feel like
activision throwing out a number was
probably very uncomfortable for them to
say
16. they probably try to aim higher you
know they probably worked their way down
with that but imagine trying to walk
into any meeting and you sitting down
for a conversation you're like i want 80
billion dollars you want what
got it the activision he probably said i
want a hundred billion dollars if we if
we really being real about the situation
probably said he want a 100 billion but
hey remember
remember when we were sitting there
talking about
something worth a hundred billion
dollars and people were attacking us
that call on addict's show
and what's crazy is
i like activision's big but i feel like
gta is huge too like i feel like if you
bought take two it wouldn't be too much
more or too much less it would be around
this to buy take two it wouldn't be like
because here's the thing people don't
realize when you buy a company you have
to buy all the assets that they own you
have to buy the market cap that they're
worth and you have to pay a little bit
more on top not a little bit more a lot
more on top usually the way i've been
described is it's like you have to pay
what the company would make in 10 years
on top
to make up for the fact that you know
that's one of those like look this is
what she's going to make in 10 years
we're going to put that on the list and
that is what we're going to pay you
that's the whole amount and that's
i don't know
how
the value of something's brought up you
know maybe that's something we can act
hold when i eventually get them on
because i need to actually ask them but
you know
pending we'll ask that but i do feel
like it would cost a lot of money to buy
take two but anyway you got any last
thing about this about this
star wars star wars thing um respawn is
a really uh respawn's a hell of a choice
for being we being real it's a hell of a
choice um
i look forward to
seeing the first person stuff and the
third person stuff the strategy stuff so
much
i'm not no strategy cat i
have not played gears tactics maybe i
should play games tactics to see if it
can it was good kind of sway my yeah i
want to see if it'll sway my
my opinion on those types of games but
oh man hey i haven't played a strategy
game i do believe since uh
just before your time man
a game called rampart on the sega
genesis well no i think it was on the
master system and i think they brought
it back up for the second genesis but i
haven't played that was
kind of well over 20 years ago but
yeah um
i'm looking forward to it because i
remember when um
the last jedi came out it was that was
the moment when it did come out that was
like we saw everybody doing like boss
rushes we saw bg getting in there um i
don't know if you you're familiar but um
stella chung but she's over there ign
she had a she had a moment that went
viral because uh she kept dying on the
boss and somebody told her to turn the
game on easy and it didn't go well she
she clapped on old budding in that
comment section
of her stream by the way she clapped she
clapped them but like nah that that that
whole game was the moment man and
i'm just with it i'm just with it i
think um
and i want you to correct me or
something star wars 13-13 that was a
game but that was cancelled right
that was the one that amy henning was
yeah
jesus
um next asked me well first off let's
get the five dollar super chat you can
read his name
because uh
says val is just a pastry 4 billion
poultry 4 billion chump change not
public so would only cost around that
much it would probably cost a little bit
more than 4 billion because i don't see
him selling it just for what it's worth
they could probably get it off him for
like 9 to 10
uh because here's the thing like when
you go for these negotiations you don't
want to go twice you want to get that up
out of there so i i do agree with you
like he could easily buy that company
that's wow and what's funny is
it was rumored a long time ago that
they were they were literally about to
buy steam and then something happened at
the last minute
i remember when i was when that when i
was in roman kicking off and i remember
that specifically that's the time i was
watching weapon whale shout out the
weapon well shout out to what podcast
i remember that and i remember smooves
saying that and i remember bond saying
then um irma blackman just just you know
responded saying there's no way they'd
ever be able to buy sting so gay bang
selling this company for whatever
microsoft can't afford it
boy how times have changed
and
microsoft walked in there
and offered him if microsoft off went in
there and offered him double what his
company's worth he probably would sell
especially now that man is probably
ready just to retire
gabe will probably dip people like all
right go take it and then they murray i
think that would be a really like if
they have that kind of money and they
can get him to sell i think steam would
be worth buying and the reason i think
steam would be worth buying is because
they the infrastructure of a pc store
and they can merge game pass with that
flawlessly and i think it would work
well for them but i don't know anything
about that we're going to go ahead and
tidy this up man i'm going to start
reaching out to people i what i want you
guys to put i want you guys to put in
the chat
people you want
to come on the attic show and me and
hustle will reach out to them i can't
guarantee they'll come on don't be put
no don't be putting
people in the chat that iop ain't even
had yet because i could get them on but
i do prefer because look we kind of like
the sister podcast the iop
and
i kind of prefer the
the the the the
the older podcast iop to girl before i
added show does so
i will get people on within reason but
if it's like don't be putting no phil
spencer or nothing in there because that
ain't gonna work i ain't doing that but
you know i'm going to get a little bit
more developers on here too because i do
want to i want to break certain things
down probably kodak no absolutely not
the dude from eu
hey nicks i know i know who you are and
nick don't get blocked in the chat stop
playing man
when they get i'll be tied up in the acg
he will be on here eventually he's been
he's busy right now because he he
reviews games and he's got he's actually
was supposed to come on a couple times
but it's just like it's hard to schedule
people because we got to work all around
our time and like at the time he wanted
to come on he was literally
working on mad reviews and i ca as a
friend i couldn't realistically be like
yo come on i had to be like yo get some
rest fab we
we watch you know we watch you alive
next week man because that man will will
work
day work
oh my god yeah his workout because is
crazy that's the homie shout out to acg
man um hey y'all make sure y'all catch
the international podcast every friday
at
1pm i think it's i think it's 1 p.m east
i don't remember i always catch it like
midway through or or i catch like the
replay
but yeah definitely go check david
joffrey okay now look look hey i
wouldn't annoy you with that i could get
david on and i'm confident i can get
david on
i asked your questions man
you can educate me on a bunch of
different stuff
that'll be dope actually mikey barra hey
listen
monkey bar work over there blizzard
right
is that is that mikey bar who works at
blizzard mm-hmm
slow-mo backslap we can get slow-mo on
oh yeah that's that's the homie yeah
yeah oh indeed dustin will be a solid
guest i could talk to dustin i'm pretty
sure i can get dustin off that that'll
be fun yeah it's the the volcano high
dabs sure well why not hey i'm not mad
at that i do want to talk to more
smaller indies too because
i i just want i want to have more fun
when it comes to these podcasts because
sure i am going to bring
um the attic spotlight back so sometimes
i'll
like instead of having the attic show on
tuesdays we'll have an attic spotlight
will break down a game that won't happen
a lot but i do want to bring those back
and if and if the news is just crazy
that week instead of having the attic
spotlight uh yeah we'll just have that
on like a friday with just myself unless
uh unless hustle can actually make it
because i know he's busy on fridays uh
mystic i have no clue who mystic is
are we talking about the streamer mystic
no he's the playstation guy
i can get king on any week like king
side of issue
i would love to talk howard
kid smooth works during the day so it's
hard to get him yeah we would have to
move
our podcast like an hour later or two
hours later
because he's getting off at like right
now
oh jesus oh yeah my condolences
yeah so you know we'll
we'll work on uh guests we'll work on
the presentation of the podcast
um you know i think if you're part of
the patreon or you're a member we might
have like a little segment because these
are about
i sometimes have to drag them out
because they're like an hour and i feel
like an hour and a half is a sweet spot
and out like 45 minutes to an hour
that's that's too short like we got to
have a little bit so we might start
doing like a little bit of q and a's if
you're like a member or a patreon
go to submit your questions i don't know
uh that's that's a pretty get cliffy b i
would like cliff to be on that would be
cool uh but go ahead
playstation channel eric greenberg
i follow uh we follow each other too i
cannot i can ask him
all right we follow each other twitter
we follow each other too i can get him
on here baby
he's a baby
i see pong i see dutch i wouldn't have
an issue working with dutch in fact i
would love to work with dutch um there
are a lot of different people yeah it
doesn't matter
yeah come one come on you know our house
is your house come on i'm gonna get jazz
cordon on too all right i'll be fine and
i'm gonna address coordinator king and
guys at the same time
oh oh i'm gonna sit back i'm gonna sit
back and just like now y'all gotta i'm
just i'm gonna just sit back and listen
i'm gonna be saying that this saturday
me and king are probably gonna stream
something on twitch so keep that in mind
this saturday okay jeff grubb jeff gruff
has said he will come on uh i wanted to
get him on during the
video game awards to explain how the
video game awards nomination works uh
but he told me that that's not a good
idea right now because he had a lot of
stuff going on in his personal life uh
he didn't have time but he said this
year he definitely can come on so we're
going to get him on
sarah bond hey hey listen listen that'd
be cool now
the dealer's death courtney ramsey
diller is different because diller has a
podcast
third tuesday too
so i don't like asking none of them to
come on because i know they have a
podcast a couple hours later thought he
was going to give colin that work
i mean i never said i was going to get
called in that way i asked calling
questions
no no i think it was referring to a gas
oh i think yeah i thought oh i thought
no no he said i thought y'all was going
to call the network nah like
and i ain't no set up type ish plus you
wouldn't you know i i respect all people
because they treated colin the same way
they treat somebody like me and i say
somebody like me just like in terms of
like sub count
the same respect and the same dignity is
given there
you know i mean just today ain't no
ain't no drama ain't no bs um we saw a
lot of that in the chat
we were blocking people left and right i
know i was i definitely was when i was
back chilling yeah
i do want to point out to you guys i
will be having playstation people on
here
it like people like um
you look i get it only on xbox you don't
like calling but here's the thing
when it comes to guests if you don't
like the guests that way can you choose
not to watch the channel
the podcast that week i don't blame you
if you don't like it that's fine but at
the end of the day we got to have as
many personalities as possible within
reason obviously i'm not going to get
someone that's left and right and just
being crazy all the time i'm not gonna
do that but
um at the end of the day colin does
speak his mind he speaks it in a very
professional way and he speaks it very
clear just because you don't like what
comes out of his mouth i get that 100
understand that and if you choose not to
watch the show that week i respect that
uh but we will get those kind of i can't
i can't let that rock add it hold on no
no support the podcast support us anyway
even if i can't be a fan at the end of
the day
if someone doesn't like at the end of
the day if someone doesn't like a guest
and they just feel that strong
i can't tell them they should watch the
show because there are sometimes i'll
watch i'll watch other podcasts and
there'll be some of like man i don't
feel like hearing them speak today and i
won't watch that show so i don't blame
them for that so you know it is what it
is you guys are entitled to make your
own thing and we will do that like bg i
tend on getting bg on again in the
future even j dub and i know a lot of
you don't like jw
and i know he's very outspoken and he
does crazy stuff
but you guys can go on my personal
channel and watch podcasts that i've
done with jw jw used to be hustle to me
jw used to literally be
on every show with me like hustle is he
is not like he is on twitter 24 7. you
got to go
no no real quick real quick okay uh a
new tweet from jason schreier from
neville
i got his tweets on on uh
on lock when they come to me um
activision is committed to releasing at
least the next three
call of duty games on playstation even
after even oh even after the xbox
acquisition according to people familiar
with the deal that's 2022 2023 in war
zone in 2023 oh okay so that's literally
why not just get this
i i never you slipping all right shout
out to john and chad for giving us that
information in the middle of the podcast
he's i'm thinking of something new yeah
my fault my bad
false alarm you're fine man so you we
will be focusing on stuff like that uh i
will be bringing obviously the lords in
from time to time cognito's a little bit
different because he's got a lot going
on right now so don't expect to see him
on anything but defining duke and the
iron lords podcast i could probably
snatch him away
uh
maybe sometime the next six months but
he's got a lot going on him so i try to
not ask him but i can get king on i'll
probably get king on here relatively
soon because it's always a good time
with king
you know
what
one last thing can i tell them to uh if
you guys want to hear more of the
podcast from sunday and you want to know
the difference between dr thunder and dr
pepper
can you guys go follow lv1 gaming on
level one gaming on youtube yeah that's
my boy right there yeah go over there
and support you know yeah please go
support family
they got a podcast tomorrow night called
double xp i gotta do that i gotta do
that oh no
someone asked about oh no it's alex um
spoiler alert
spoiler alert
alex is going to be scheduled to come on
iop eventually so
um
we will have him eventually
on iop i don't know when but
we are in the process of doing that
um
we are doing a little bit more like you
guys saw chase money
we're doing a little bit more of dual
shows so i'm not going to really go into
like who's going to be in it but we do
have another dual show
coming up in the next couple months i
think you guys will enjoy
personally if i can say if i can lobby
for a guest as well i definitely want to
see uh see i see byron in the chat yeah
baron get baron over here too here's
another one man baron dallas the guy
that you have rapping every week on um
the i lost podcast in the very beginning
yeah yeah that's another one like it's
it's quite a few of them who have a
whole lot to offer um
i definitely
like i never really had a chance to
really kick it with 3mg like that and
i've been watching this content for a
real long time so that'll be dope for me
griffin gaming i'm not sure about that
one sir yeah i got nothing against
griffin but i don't really particularly
like his uh content because sometimes i
feel like
i don't want my brand being socialized
with his brain like and i don't mind his
brand his brand's not bad
it's just when it comes to the way i
want my brain represented we just have a
little bit of different of opinions on
how that goes and like i actually what's
funny is griffin gaming literally made a
video about kid smooth and saying that
he didn't know kit smooth and then we
actually had video like we have dm shane
that we know each other so like it is
what it is i got nothing against the man
he can make the type of content he wants
uh you know i prefer actually that type
of content i prefer someone like um like
alex because i feel like alex does it a
little bit like
more respectful in the in that case like
i just don't like that kind of content
in general and it's not that he gets any
one of those i just don't like that
we're going to bring people up on a
channel and just talk about them like i
don't know that it's just that's just my
opinion and i got nothing against that
kind of content it's just i it's not my
type of content so i don't feel
comfortable bringing people on that do
that type of content if that makes sense
um
uh the we gotta find out superchat the
otaku fix just showing support also
looks like according to activision the
next three called uh games will be on
ps5 oh yeah i could see that happening i
could see that happening uh luca
definitely is a possibility i do know
she works i just don't know what times
so you know it is what it is but i
appreciate you all for coming on my
voice is going away i gotta go
i gotta go ahead and end this man
well like i said here in the next couple
weeks uh you know we we might i can get
next-gen but i feel like sometimes he's
a little bit too much
uh but you know i definitely i'm ready
for that yeah i i feel like i'll reach i
will reach out to david jaffe though i i
am gonna reach out to him uh because he
cusses a lot we want him on ilp
but he he's real loose in the language
like real real loose so we might put him
on put him on the attic show
see if he could a tone a little bit
because if we there's cussing on here i
don't like it but it's not a huge deal
but if there's cussing on iop we will
address that mid and i saw people
addressing saying that no one called out
calling for cussing the first time we
usually give people one or two uh we we
were trying to get let him get his a
point across but after he dropped the
f-bomb that's what i said i reminded
because people will atone to their
language
when they're reminded but sometimes
people forget because you guys got to
keep in mind there's very few podcasts
on the internet that says no cussing
you're right so people forget all the
time fentanyl no issue with them another
person i just prefer to stay away from
the type of con that they make uh but
we're not gonna go too much into that
it's just
no issue with these people i know people
are gonna go back and then say that we
talking mad smack no issue with their
content i just prefer
the streams not to cross that's all uh
but
jaffee would be a good guest i would
look into that it just
it just depends man because jaffee could
be real extra sometimes man he really
can nothing against jaffe but man he
could be extra but anyway i appreciate
everyone for coming in here uh paris
slowly i would ask i doubt paris would
come on here i know he's a busy person
but i appreciate everyone for coming on
on here and until next week
this is
lord addict and hustle motivating we're
out